Tyler lepley can have my throat anytime
he wants
all right hey what's going on y'all my
name is Tyler lepley and I'm here with
BuzzFeed reading some thirst tweets
[Music]
can't believe I'm just now discovering
Harlem on Prime and it got me thirsting
over Tyler lepley all over again well uh
we got season two coming out keep
discovering we got a lot more for you I
want Tyler lovely to spit in my mouth
that was open wide second I'll just play
you need to find God hold on I wish
Tyler lovely and Miracle wise would ask
me to join them or something I mean damn
answer my DMs uh I don't know she she
ain't sharing me she a little
territorial about me I don't know about
that one I want Tyler leppy to grab me
up and fling me across the room
um all right I'm gonna go to the next
one
Tyler level is 1998 fine I thought they
weren't reissuing that model but God I
was born in 87 so um yeah 98 I was I was
still a baby I don't know about that uh
but I appreciate you I'll be having
really raunchy thoughts about Tyler
lepley I need to go to church yes you do
matter of fact I need to go to church
I've been looking for a good church in
La so if y'all got uh if y'all got some
ideas tweet me them as well Ian is fine
okay like where do I find one of him at
they got they got that on Amazon matter
of fact they do he ran over in Harlem
check us out on Friday my Lord titled up
to even find him in person I want to
throw the drawers I don't even have them
on at this point so I'll find them in
person so basically you're saying like I
I look like hell on TV I won't hold that
against you but okay Tyler lepley can
have my throat anytime he wants um all
right I would eat Tyler of his ass with
no hesitation hold on what's up what
type of tweets y'all got me reading I
sell my soul to lick the sweat from
titled up with his armpits I I don't I
don't think you want to do that I do
appreciate you though every time that
[__] big dick having fine ass
yellow ass Tyler let me pop on my Ig my
coochie gets hard why is he so damn
beautiful oh see I see you blushing over
there you had me read it now you
blushing how did that work we're gonna
put this one down put all jokes aside
though whether it's like raunchy tweets
or people are like you know talking you
know people are or a professional love
to me or saying they love or hate me at
the end of the day truly honestly I just
feel the love like I can just feel the
support that they got because truly as
an artist we don't go nowhere without it
no matter what your Tweet is what your
DM is shoot them out because as much as
I can I want to give that support back
so I really appreciate it and I love
y'all huge shout out and huge thank you
to BuzzFeed for uh showing us in the
life that y'all always do and make sure
y'all catch Harlem so I'm watching with
y'all thank you
[Music]
foreign